[Music]
yo so cologne it's a lot of them out
there some little bit too overpowering
some you can't even smell and some are
just Oh
so how do you know where's the best
cologne for men well that's what we're
going to talk about in this video so
let's get to it I have a dream hey guys
if you're new here to my channel
subscribe and click the notification
belt so you won't miss any of the next
videos now let's start with the first
cologne Vince Camuto Tara oh my goodness
this is by far my most favorite cologne
did an amazing job by mixing the notes
together in a perfect balance and so the
top notes at your smell is citrus
geranium sandalwood rhubarb tonka bean
and vanilla it's got this very manly
smell but it's not too overpowering as
well my wife really loves it every time
I wear it she gives me these nice
comments yeah alright anyway it's got
this nice woody smell with a soft musk I
cannot go wrong with this one I'll add
it for in the video description as
always so you can go ahead and check it
out
do Savva i gotta mention this one
because it's a plastic and it smells
really good the only problem I have with
it is that there's so many guys that has
this cologne so if you don't want to
smell like every second guy that really
likes cologne and this is not the one
for you but it does smell great and if
he doesn't bother you then you can try
it out the top notes are bergamot and
pepper
versace euros this is another one of my
favorites because this is for a guy that
is passionate strong confident because
when you smell it get these top notes of
vanilla mint tonka bean green apple
lemon and um peroxide so it gives you
this nice fresh smell that will please
any crowd around you Nordica 4-h for men
now you know that guard leathery kind of
smell well this is not it this guy
smells fresh vibrant and kind of summery
this cologne has a rich fusion between
dewy moss and refined woody amber as its
base notes and the top notes are green
leaves and apple and like all the other
cologne I'll add it free in the video
description go and check out the
customer reviews I think this guy got
over 4000 of happy reviews from guys
just like me and you Hugo Boss Feist
he's got this really sexy citrusy gonna
smell of top notes of iseman vetiver and
Welty it's got this nice uplifting smell
and it's not too overpowering as well
lasted a long time and this cologne is
actually perfect to wear in any kind of
casual environment also here on a date
with your girlfriend or wife she'll try
to hang around you the whole night just
to get this smell now if you're looking
for a lion fling cologne that smells
great Dolce and Gabbana light blue is
the one for you
it has this combination of bitter notes
and spice with sweet undertones Maynard
you get is grapefruit bergamot pepper
orange rosemary and Brazilian rosewood
so it smells great it is light it is
clean I will last you the whole day you
know at the end of the day to get the
best cologne that work for you in your
personal life you have to take this
journey of trying out different colognes
so you can really find your own personal
tastes that might take some time but if
you want the journey to be a little bit
cheaper than do what I did you don't
have to buy the whole big bottle
especially if you're not sure if you
don't like it yet you can join a
subscription-based company that sends
you a 30 day supply of Cologne everyone
you're choosing so you go online you
check out the Cologne you like ah I like
to try this one next time and then you
try it and just say no this is not a
sponsored video because I should
probably noticed on my channel
especially for a subscriber I don't
really do those a lot anyway so you try
out different Cologne every month until
you develop your taste you like to try
it out I got my subscribers a 30%
discount code so check it out in a video
description off your first order but if
you liked the video give it a thumbs up
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
video
Cheers
you